from livestock to crops new technologies
are becoming an intrinsic part of a
farmers working day resulting in more
and better agricultural products
precision agriculture supports farmers
with more sustainable practices
precision farming aims to generate more
results and agricultural activities
while using few resources such as water
energy fertilizers and pesticides it
mainly uses information technology data
from satellites and the Internet of
Things the aim is not only to make life
easier for farmers but also to increase
yields in the most resource efficient
way possible for instance ground sensors
who can calculate the optimal time for
crop irrigation using the least amount
of water or this robot can milk cows
automatically precision agriculture is
common sense but it's using technologies
from the eye in the sky and all sorts of
wonderful things to make the farmer's
job easier to target to reduce costs to
reduce wasteful and runoff of inputs
which can impact negatively on the
environment by 2050 the global
population is expected to have increased
from 7 to 10 billion to respond to this
demographic challenge agricultural
yields would need to grow by 70 to 100
percent if 3 billion people more to give
good quality of food the right quantity
so we have to see how can we change as a
pattern what we eat in CFO we really
need a lot of technology and I think
certain kind of robots will also make it
easier to harvest the different
qualities at the right time in the right
moment the next challenge is to teach
farmers how to use these new
technologies our family farm structure
is so important to us but use every
available technology in a wise way
empower our farmers particularly our
young farmers to see these opportunities
because I know they want to seize them
if they're given the opportunity to do
that and to have a win-win for consumers
producers and the environment
for those who would like to know more
precision farming were the subject of a
study by the European Parliament Stowe a
panel on Science and Technology it's
accessible to all just a few ticks away